okay I have my day free I'm gonna find a
therapist by the end of the week there
are a lot of women therapists nearby but
do I need an Asian therapist oh my god I
would love to be with this therapist but
my insurance doesn't cover it
of course the therapist my friend
recommend is available in six months and
of course the therapist that that
therapist recommended is all booked up -
are people gonna think I'm crazy if they
know I'm getting therapy maybe I don't
need therapy after all maybe I just need
more sleep
I'll start an audio diary that's
basically therapy what is my mom gonna
think when I tell her I want therapy you
need to pray more why waste the money on
therapist wait what's a deductible oh my
god my insurance deductible is so high
should I switch insurance it's gonna be
such a pain in the ass this therapist
wants to see me every week at $100 a
session I can't afford that you have no
hours after work or on the weekend
honey I have work I can't see you any
time except after work or on the weekend
how do you have any clients do your
clients have jobs okay it's not like I
have an actual disorder I'm not
depressed or anything serious do I
actually need a therapist well I've
never been to a therapist so I don't
know if I'm depressed maybe maybe I just
need to go and then I'll find out ok
google' am I depressed I don't recognize
this number they work after hours they
accept my insurance they are so easy to
talk to and I have an appointment good
for you girl taking care of yourself